u.s. midterm elections are less than a
month away but the latest polls show
that Americans could care less and the
group that cares the least 18 to 29 year
olds so I'm here at UC Berkeley's campus
to talk to students to see if that's
true and how much they know about the
issues are you excited about the US
midterm elections
I usually don't pay attention when are
the election in November do you know
when the midterm elections are obviously
that does but I should find out I mean I
was zoom in November but I don't know
can we interview about us midterm
elections are you registered to vote do
you plan to vote wait every term
elections important to you hmm
so maybe they're not following midterms
too closely but how much do they know
about the California governor who's up
for re-election time for a pop quiz
who's the California Governor Jerry
Brown gerrae
no idea I was one time when about Lu
governor's they all do the same thing we
are looking but I still want to know why
is it that Millennials just don't care
about midterm elections as Millennials
we weren't really big change and we want
to start at sort of like a grassroots
level but people don't look at like the
mid-level thing people want crazies like
large vast movements like you saw in the
Obama campaign and so I think that we
only think that change can really occur
on like a national scale level a lot of
us are just focused on like midterms and
our social lives when people aren't
informed about what it is how it's going
to affect them then it's very easy I'd
like not care it seems like others are
just downright disillusioned with
politics like Congress is just so
impotent like they're just sitting there
squabbling with each other
actually I'm disillusioned right now why
I don't really like voting for one
puppet over the other
like there's more important stuff going
on in the room like what like Ebola like
Isis like what's going on
like who cares about midterm elections
we're like pure diamonds by like it's
disease that it gets easily controlled
before going all the way to freaking in
the Middle East to fight a caliphate
it's not really Islamic so that's what
UC Berkeley students had to say about
the upcoming US midterm elections how
about you how much do you know
want more download the aj+ mobile app
and during the conversation available in
your app store now